I haven't been to women
that often recently. But.
Like the kids that i grew up
with that are still there.
You know i think it's lost a lot of magic
in the in it's still a very good far out
place but just the period
that we grew up just you know after queer
stress filled it was just something about
it that just the era of kids and
adults that you know grew out of
that experience is incredible
and you know it's it's be hard to
reproduce you know i think just a one off
incredible time.
From.
Well i've got some friends who live
in a community is still not in
but nearby they come here they're doing
wonderful the same really good kids really
close this some i mean of a few friends
they're getting they're still the drug
scene of course one of the reasons. When
the change came to move to the beach.
I'm glad that i kind of
moved from the image there.
I mean you can't deny that
there is a drug scene in them
but it was controlled around us as kids.
It was never a problem at all
but i mean few of my friends you know
sure they're into the drug scene a bit
but i mean.
But then there's the kids who aren't
and they're doing wonderful
things who are still there.
You know so i mix you know i think that.
It is that even the
kids who have moved out
and need to see mean spread
out. Everywhere really.
I have to say most really happy like.
Really i mean i can say
to be one person one kid.
So called he's probably not a kid
anymore but really one person he was
and happy i mean i will
be absent there and.
But yeah it was just i think it produced.
A group of kids who are
growing up to be optimists.
I mean you know bad things
happen and we get in bad need
and we all think all the whole
world's going to former top of this
but in comparison to when elsewhere.
Most the time we can discuss how we can
handle this problem. You know it's.
I know i mean it might just be me and i
might have you know there's always i will.
I would have turned out the same anyway.
But i really don't think i would have.
I just yeah it's like there's always
the branding i'll the hippie kids
that grew up poor them you know. The
nat period their life was wasted.
But i don't now they're
living in suburbia.
Ok we can reform them where i think it's
the opposite. You know like you'll see.
You can pick them out the kids
that grew up with that lifestyle
and they're the real there's a
vibrant they're the leaders.
You know that none of this or that a dud
ones are just in the corner smoking
and stuff you know they're they're
really magic kids you know like.
A lot of kids i know have
moved away from them
and they're doing wonderful things in the
city like really outgoing leadership
stuff you know academically
art everything you know
and to whereas people saying oh you know
they grew up on a farm there you know
parents were hippies
and stuff you know they probably won't
make it as far as if they'd go up there.
I think it's the opposite.
I think just the way we look at life
is totally different like just.
Our upbringing has made us have a totally
different perspective of life which i
think is really good
and it's just benefiting me fully in high
school in everything around me. You know.
It's really just in. Every i
run again and muses me no end.
People say oh you know.
Do you feel that those years were
wasted or you know people think that
that was you know the poor hippy
kids what a waste. I mean.
It really isn't really because i have
to say it's the total opposite they see
it was just a she was so it's
hard to express i mean really.
They were just totally amazing
and it was like as anything now i'm wasting
my time getting in a chair say i should
be out there doing it. I mean realistically
i don't know that's another story.
But you know i'm doing what i'm doing and
i'm happy doing it. So that's fine but.
I have to say that waste is
not even a word i mean it's.
You couldn't even you couldn't even think
of saying oh yeah wasted years as a joke
you know being sarcastic. If you just
couldn't really because it was just.
Basically was just an amazing time
and living in it. We decide i am.
This is really cool and haven't
heaps of fun but reflecting back on
and i think it's just
when you really get blase of a way i really
think because we've had so much fun as
a kid i can't live our lives.
So my free for you know they
said you know it's really now
that you're hearing other kids
stories and their upbringing
and realizing what how i was you
know that that an incomprehensibly
that i was even applicable.
I had a totally different lifestyle as
thank god i did you know it was wonderful.
Like you know he kids how they grew up and
today dada. And you think how boring.
You know you think wow i
just think when i was
that age i was off camping i was of learning
how to make a boomerang as throw it.
I was off our learn how to make our
own paper and things like that.
You know you think that those kids they
don't have and they might not never have
and it's like i'm just so thankful but
i'm also thankful in a way that the time
that i spent nimbin was real.
Good but now then i'm out i'm glad
that i'm like work i'm free to use the
knowledge that we've had since we're kids
but go along in the lifestyle
that we are here away from nimbin
that's always a part of us you know.
It's like i think if i still in nimbin now
you know i'd be totally different scene
there might be you know i might be
doing wonderful things in nimbin
but i also there's the drug side.
You know as things on the time i
spent nimbin was just incredible
and i'm really thankful that i grew up
there was this incredible experience.
For.